hi guys
welcome back to another live session by
simply learn for today's session the
topic of discussion
is how to become a back-end developer
so if you're wondering how to become a
back-end developer what skills are
required and what the responsibilities
are
then you're in the right place but let's
wait for a while for more people
to tune in
i'd also like to thank all our viewers
for actively participating in these
sessions
alright so uh whilst you're at it if you
haven't subscribed to our channel
already make sure to hit the subscribe
button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update okay so i see a lot of people
tuning in
all right so i think we're good to begin
now i'm sure all of you use social media
applications
now every time you click on a video
scroll through a feed
perhaps search for something the
corresponding information is displayed
on your screen
now these applications provide an
excellent user experience
but how is this achieved you must know
that every application comprises of two
parts
there's the front end and then there's
the back end
the front end is what the user deals
with and the back end is what makes this
happen
in other words the back end includes an
application
a server and a database the backend
application
fetches the data from the database and
processes
all client requests the result of this
is made visible to the user
so now the question arises who is a
back-end developer
a back-end developer's role is to focus
on details
like building an effective website
architecture scripting and writing code
that serves as a means of communication
between the website's database and the
browser
and lastly to ensure data integrity and
consistency
so now let's look at the skills required
to become a back-end developer
it is vital for you to have good
understanding
of programming concepts like data
structures and algorithms
this includes stacks queues linked lists
trees and graphs sorting algorithms and
search algorithms
next up is programming languages and
frameworks
one of the most critical skills of a
back-end developer
is the depth of knowledge in back-end
programming languages
this includes proficiency in javascript
and its environments
like node.js and expressjs next
is java this language was particularly
built from the ground up
to be run on server side popular
frameworks include spring and java
server faces
next up is python which is the most
popularly used language today
it is flexible and easy to use python
frameworks like
django and flask are used for back-end
development
and lastly there's c-sharp and it's
frameworks like asp.net core
and asp.net mvc
other languages include perl php and
ruby
now biggest back-end and front-end
developers work so closely together
it is also helpful to have a
foundational understanding
of front-end web languages like html and
css
now proficiency is essential not only
for performing daily
tasks but also for working alongside
front-end developers for developing
solutions
next we have database management systems
a back-end developer writes code that is
used to perform
relational mapping to fetch data from
the database
some popularly used dbms are mysql
sql server and postgresql
next up is version control again popular
ones are git
and subversion they help manage the
project files
and keep track of the entire history of
things
that the developer is working on
and lastly this cloud hosting platforms
these platforms allow you to deploy your
product on the cloud service provider
so that it can be accessed from the
world wide web
most popular ones are amazon web
services
google cloud platform heroku and
microsoft azure of course
there are non-technical skills that are
required of back-end developers
those who choose this profession should
be comfortable with analytical processes
have well developed problem solving
capabilities
be interested in emerging technologies
have good communication skills
and be able to work independently and
sometimes as a part of a collaborative
team
now that you're familiar with the skills
let's have a look at the
responsibilities of a back-end developer
first up is forming an understanding of
the performance
needs and goals of the website to
develop effective successful solutions
development and management of
application programming interfaces
development of systems for websites to
accept and securely store data
such as those required for payment
processing systems
then there's writing code testing and
development solutions
for correlated issues
then this organization of system logic
other responsibilities also include
development of site architecture using
proper methodologies
like agile scrum framework and also
providing solutions
to system problems lastly let's have a
look at the salaries of a backend
developer
the average salary of a back-end
developer in the united states
is around 102 000 us dollars per year
the average salary of a back-end
developer in india
is around 7 lakhs 23 000 indian rupees
per annum
but how can we at simply learn help you
now if you wish to make a career in this
field
then you can navigate to our simply
learn website
and look for the courses that suit you
best we offer the full stack web
developer main stack masters program
there's also the full stack java
developer program and we offer a
post-graduate program
in full stack web development you can go
ahead and click on it
to get a brief overview of the course if
it suits your requirements
you can go ahead and purchase the course
so with that we come to the
end of this live session if you have any
doubts let us know in the comment
section below
we'll get back to you immediately so
watch out for more live videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
you